sherry is with us in Phoenix hi sherry
how are you I'm good how are you
better than I deserve what's up well I
had a quick question for you
my husband and I we started your program
about a month ago and we are actually
kind of to the point I've talked to
credit card companies wearing a good 7
$70,000 in debt mostly because we opened
up a new business and we invested the
money but now we're to the point to
where we can't even make our four walls
and we don't want to we don't want to
clean bankruptcy why are you can't why
can't you make your four walls your
income going down it has gone down he
used to work we haven't been used well
we haven't been used to the money that
he's been getting paid mostly because he
was having to work out of town a lot he
was in Alaska for like four months and
we have two children so for him to be
able to be home more we had to take a
pay cut and that's when we decided to
invest in this business so that's why
the paychecks have gone completely down
okay so he has a side business he does
yes
what is this side business it is a we
invest in and then foot housing what
would you say like flipping houses
you're broke and you decided to start
flipping houses we've been trying to the
best that we can try to find one good no
that's absolutely that this is a good
way to go bankrupt for sure yeah no you
should not be flipping houses when you
are broke and seventy thousand dollars
in debt and can't even make your bills
so what is his day job job is he does
x-ray on pipeline so he is a good job
it's not a good job it doesn't pay your
household bills what do you want is your
what is uh what is his income it
fluctuates one coming year maybe what
time of year eighty you can't live on
eighty thousand dollars a year yeah why
Wow how much is your room we actually
have a rental in Colorado and we do have
a house here in Phoenix
okay sell the rental in Colorado that's
what yeah that's what I've got yesterday
about doing okay and what is it worth it
is worth I believe 2:30 and what do you
owe on it we go one sixty oh good
that'll pay off a bunch of the credit
card debt sell back tomorrow if you
don't have that on the market by Monday
I'm gonna come to Phoenix and kick your
butt this is ridiculous
what is your current home worth my
current home is worth 225 Oh what do you
owe on it we owe probably about 215 okay
and what is your income
I stay home how many kids we have two
children there is one thing that I did
want to ask you about we are locked into
we're wanting to have a third child but
we have to do IVF and we are locked IVF
oh okay and we're locked into doing that
because we made our deposit if we don't
go through with it we will lose that
deposit how much was your deposit it was
five hundred and what's the follow
through fifteen forty eight hundred
forty eight hundred okay yes all right
and you have seventy thousand dollars in
debt and you have a house in Colorado
what do you own your cars our cars has
paid off mine is a forerunner our
payments are like five hundred a month
which I've told him to get rid of it
smelly okay good so we're selling the
car we're selling the house we're going
to finish the IV
we're gonna pay cash for it and he's
gonna pick up an extra job I'm sorry
he's not gonna see his children he's
getting ready to lose everything this is
what you do when you're up against the
wall you go to work yeah a lot it's not
a lifetime sentence but for the next two
years he needs to be working 80 hours a
week get this dadgum family out of the
ditch yeah and no you're not flipping
any houses good lord yeah yeah yeah
$3,000 to go to that weekend class crap
didn't you
we paid $70,000 and while in total we
got asked to be part of the next level
so we had to invest more money into that
next level of get screwed look exactly I
know I know
unbelievable I wasn't sure I tried
talking to credit-card companies because
of course I don't want to so here's your
doing you need a list you need to list
out your budget I don't give a crap
about your credit cards just let them
sit there if they scream and your credit
gets messed up I don't care right now
you need to list your debt your food
lights and water pay your house payment
pay your car payment until you get it
sold
you have enough coming in to do that you
were wrong you can meet your four walls
$80,000 a year we'll do that plus he's
got three extra jobs now I just gave
them to him real jobs that pay money not
that are getting it not that are ripping
him off you should not have to pay money
to make money in this case you go get a
job making money honk every delivering
pizza but whatever if he can get if he
can get ot on his current job take all
the OT because he's probably worth more
there than he is anywhere else exactly
our side gigs in that industry because
apparently Alaska and now he still do an
x-ray so he's a pipeline guy he probably
has some pretty specialized skills that
are pretty valuable if we put him to
work right and let's go earn some money
and clean this mess up
the credit cards can sit I don't want
them to but they're the last thing on
the list to pay here get rid of the car
get rid of the house in collar
immediately immediately and then all
you've got to do is buy food lights and
water pay your house payment you can do
that that's your four walls four walls
are necessities everything else after
that might be in trouble for a while but
I don't think it is I think you can
probably pay it all if you get on a
really really tight budget beans and
rice rice and beans and no you're not
going on vacation not anytime soon and
no you're not going to see the inside of
a restaurant unless you're working there
oh and by the way anything you can do to
pick up some extra income while you're
at home with these kids would be awesome
thousand dollars a month changes this
formula pretty dramatically I don't care
if you're watching somebody else's kid
that wouldn't be a bad thing for a
little while something along those lines
anything I don't care if you've got a
some kind of specialized training
yourself and skills you could bring it
in home and do that two or three hours a
day and you are a home economist you are
a coupon queen you are a consignment
sale lady and you're cooking from
scratch because it's healthier and a
whole lot cheaper and I if you're gonna
be home that's the kind of stuff you're
gonna be doing and I don't mind you
being home I'm with you on the on the go
love that and I'm with you on the goal
of the next baby I'm a gay issue with
that but don't put any down any more
deposits if this round of IVF doesn't
work until we get this household out of
a ditch the last thing you need is the
stress around all this stuff going on
and and then add to that the stress of
trying to have another child that just
puts you a hand bless your heart that's
a mess but you guys are going to take
some action here that that's wise and
that is long-term thinking because
you've made several unwise decisions so
far then you're gonna have to offset
that and turn it around but that that's
what's going on here you don't have a
four walls problem you can eat you can
pay your lights and water and you can
pay your house payment and you can pay
your car payment till you get it sold
you can pay and that's the deal so you
know it just it doesn't make sense you
you can do your you can do your four
walls that's the way to go so
thank you for the call